You have learned quite a lot in the last six units.
You have learned about how to recognize that a problem is difficult to solve.
You have learned about the theory of NP completeness surrounding those problems,
and you have also learned some powerful techniques to deal with NP complete problems
so that they might even be solvable in practice despite their general hardness.
Now, there's one question we haven't yet looked at and that is kind of the ultimate question.
Are there any problems that no computer, no matter how powerful,
no matter with how much time is able to solve, and the answer surprisingly turns out to be yes.
In this unit, I will show you that there are some deceptively simple problems
for which we can prove that no computer,
no matter how powerful will ever be able to solve them.